let's see if we can add 3/10 to 7
hundredths and I encourage you to try
adding these two fractions on your own
first before I work through it and I'll
give you one hint right now it's very
hard to add these fractions you have
your adding 3/10 to 7 hundredths you're
adding two different fractions with two
different denominators so what I would
encourage you to do is try to rewrite
3/10 in a way that it has a hundred as a
denominator or so it's expressed in
terms of hundredths and then see if you
can add them well I'm assuming you've
given a go at it let's see how we can
rewrite 3/10 and I'll try to visualize
it so what I have done here so this you
could consider a hole and this is a hole
as well and this whole is divided into
tenths 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so what
would three tenths look like well it
would be 1 2 & 3 of the tenths 3 of the
tents now what would happen if you turn
it if you took each of those tenths and
you divided them if you took each of
those tents and you divided them into 10
more sections so you're essentially
taking each of those tents and you're
dividing them into ten sections well you
have 10 sections and then each of them
will have ten subsections in it so
you're going to have you're going to
have a hundredths then the sections are
going to describe hundreds so ten we
write it this way ten ten times ten
times ten
you're then going to have hundreds and
3/10 would be equivalent to how many of
these hundredths well each of these
tents will now become ten so you're
going to have you're going to have ten
twenty and we color them in better so
that's 10 20 and then 30 hundredths so
this part right over here this
get my tool right this part right over
here this is going to be three times ten
three times ten which is going to be
equal to thirty ten times ten is equal
to 100 so this is how we're going to
change the denominator instead of
thinking in terms of ten so we're going
to think in terms of hundredths and now
our numerator the aquit 3/10 is
equivalent to 30 hundredths so we can
rewrite this fraction we essentially
multiplied the numerator by 10 we
multiplied the numerator by 10 and we
multiplied the denominator by 10 which
didn't change the value of the fraction
it still represents the same the same it
still represents 3/10 of the whole so
when you do that you end up we can
rewrite this thing as 30 over 100 3/10
is equivalent to 30 over 100 we add that
to 7 over 100 or another way of thinking
about it 3/10 is the same thing as 30
hundredths and we add that to 7
hundredths well now we're going to have
30 plus 7 hundredths so now we're going
to have 30 plus 7 30 plus 7 hundredths
30 plus 7 hundredths or we could say
that this is now going to be 37
hundredths 37 hundredths so this extra 7
that we're adding here maybe I'll do
this in not that's the same color this
extra sevenths let me do this in a new
color
this extra the 700s that we're adding
that's going to be 1/2 let me paint that
in a little bit clearer so that's 1/2 so
it gets us all the way to 7 let's see 1
2 3 so 7 hundredths 7 hundredths is
right over there so let me get back to
my pen so that whoops this right over
here is 7 out of the hundred so 30
hundredths plus 7 hundredths is going to
get us to 37 1
it's